hey wyatt good to see you man how are
you
i'm good are you at all concerned that
when fans
watch this show and they see you in this
costume that they're gonna say out loud
that's not america's ass
no and and i can
i can i can definitely say if you're
worried about that you're worried about
you're worried about the wrong things
it's your mind out of the gutter this is
such a cool
idea for to take the story because
there's so much depth to even this
character some people would say that
he's even more interesting in a way
uh than steve is um
i think that's that just depends on the
way you look at it i i
i there's gonna be lots of people who um
connect to different characters for
different reasons
um i always just go and do the character
that was presented to me and written
and try to enhance it in ways that i can
ways that i think will
behoove the show or the movie and
it's like apples and oranges in a way
steve yeah it's steve rogers
chris evans it's been it's been like
marvel universe he
helped create it um and so the mcu has
taken on this sort of amorphous
beingness thing where there's a reality
to the
to the mcu and there's a reality to the
people playing them
and it's fun to co-mingle but i've
always been more of a person who i just
do
i just do the character that i'm playing
and then um people put on do it whatever
they want
to it's not my job to do that yeah very
cool
um you talked about actually auditioning
for
you know steve rogers captain america
like 10 years ago
was there any connection to that this
time around like did marvel give you any
indication that that was
part of why you're here today no no i
think that if anything that would have
been more of a
would have reminded them of that they
would have been like maybe not
that would be more of a reason to to not
i remember
uh it was just it was a coincidence in
that
um i think everybody in the world
probably auditioned for captain america
in the first one i'm sure it was a they
cast a wide net i'm sure they went to
you know
we're all over to try and find captain
america
and uh and so everybody that was
auditioning 10 years ago
anybody that would have gotten this part
would have also have auditions for
captain america 10 years ago so
there's a coincidence aspect to it and
then there's a numbers
part to it that i think i was just you
know i'm
just stat
[Music]
well man we're um super stoked for more
on this series this is like
the one i've been the most excited for
yeah
i can't wait to see what happens with
you me too
all right all the best man take care
you